edweena Brady's baby fox was born with
Down syndrome two days before Christmas
he'll be in the special care unit of
York hospitals maternity wing for a few
more days it's been a difficult time for
mum made easier by the midwives be very
attentive and the staff and in special
care have been amazing as well see
that's the job but they they obviously
big they do the job because they love
the jobs yeah it's been it's been a nice
experience in a way but obviously quite
a hard one but the midwives have been
fantastic another mother singing the
praises of maternity staff is the
Duchess of Cambridge she spent two days
with midwives in London an experience
she described as a privilege but it's a
part of the NHS that has been
understaffed for years in England we're
about two and a half thousand Midwife
short which is slightly you know less
than we've had in the past we have got a
number of midwives who are retiring and
of course they their experience is
wonderful so we've got an opportunity to
try and help them stay a bit longer but
also an opportunity to bring more
midwives into the profession the
midwives in York appreciate the role
message of support seeing it as a morale
boost for a profession that is demanding
and rewarding in equal measure if people
tell you that it is a challenging job
but I think until you actually start
doing it then you realise obviously how
challenging it is and that you do have
to commit we've committed to it but
obviously where the challenges come the
rewards as well so it's entirely worth
it do you ever feel as though you are
under pressure or can you always cope I
think we can all feel like we're under
pressure but the one thing that stands
out is the great teamwork throughout the
department and I would do all worked
great in there together as a team for
Rebecca and Anthony the arrival of baby
Ben was the perfect Christmas present
after over 36 hours of labor and
ever-present throughout of course the
midwives they provide care for me but
also us as a family as well and it's
that whole journey from
when when it all starts happening right
up until like he's arrived you've always
got that kind of support and that's
invaluable baby Freddie arrived on
Boxing Day two and a half weeks
premature we've had a lot of support
here from the staff like from when we
first were admitted in triage labor
wards and then coming on here as well
it's about a lot of support yeah it's
been frustrating not be able to go home
but it's helped having the extra support
while you're in doesn't it so have been
fantastic the Duchess described the work
of the midwives as humbling and crucial
none of the mothers here would disagree
Fraser Maud Sky News York